la première fois vous apparaissez à la
télévision c'est pour protester avec
d'autres élèves de l'ena vous occuper
l'école pour refuser son transfert de
paris à strasbourg nous sommes en 91
vous avez 24 ans
[Musique]
ils s'y sentent tellement bien dans leur
école parisienne de la rue de
l'université qu'ils n'ont plus envie de
la quitter mais mme lanusse pense pas
qu'un jour j'aurai l'honneur de me
coucher sur la moquette l'amphithéâtre
jean moulin mais ça c'est démontré
malgré son que loin d'être coupée la
réalité sociale de ce pays nous pouvions
garder près des préoccupations theater
le grand public ne connaît mal sinon il
serait qu'on n'est pas les polars en
cravate et henri stoll
ne reconnaît pas quentin de passe dans
la rue nous sommes des hommes et des
femmes comme tout le monde comme disait
ma camarade des énarques qui ont un père
une mère j'espère que tout le monde en
est conscient et tout ce que vous direz
sourds oui oui je voudrais devenir
combat perdu avec le recul vous diriez
mauvais combat
notre combat c'était pour dire que les
énarques et devaient être formés non pas
en province mais au plus près les
administrations centrales ce
déménagement à strasbourg il était très
symbolique c'était l'idée de
dalé m en province les mets aux
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui l'ena va être
une école de formation de toutes les
administrations
et aujourd'hui ce campus à strasbourg il
a trouvé son équilibre mais à l'époque
ça nous paraissait assez démagogique
comme proposition ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas toujours écouter les jeunes ou
qui n'ont pas toujours raison ça veut
dire que
en fait c'était vraiment surtout du
symbolique et que ça nous paraissait
effectivement
uniquement symbolique et pas très très
efficace sur dans la pratique d'ailleurs
pendant des années les énarques ont eu
des problèmes à faire venir leurs
professeurs jusqu'à strasbourg parce que
les professeurs ne voulait pas venir oui
maintenant l'école a trouvé son son
équilibre et c'est tant mieux pour elle
[Musique]